here with reaction south carolina
senator lindsey graham
um
lindsey i i know you and i have both
been viewed as hawks but if we don't
learn
right from our mistakes and our
successes
then we're doomed to
repeat failure
now what happened in afghanistan ended
up being an unmitigated failure in a
disaster we can't be
en engaged in these foreign conflicts in
perpetuity
reagan showed us the way with the
mujahideen and with the freedom fighting
contrast
and i would argue trump showed us with
isis solomonia and baghdadi do you agree
with that
yeah 100 percent president trump said
something today that i think is going to
was really smart he said a hundred years
from now they're gonna look back at this
time in history and wondering what the
hell were these people doing
what did you suggest you suggest that
the war criminal putin who is murdering
ukrainian men women and children by the
thousands now should go and that created
controversy i really don't care how he
goes i don't care if they turn him over
the hague to be a war crimes trial where
he should be
they give him an early buy out or
somebody takes him out otherwise
you're right to want him to go and to
those who can't say that what the hell
is wrong with you why can't you say
openly to the russian people you need to
take care of this problem putin for your
own good your country will never go
anywhere as long as he's your leader and
look what he's doing in ukraine and
throughout the world so president trump
gave a 20-minute interview today that i
wish every american could heard it was
the way to handle this problem he says
you can't let a guy with nuclear weapons
dictate the world because he has nuclear
weapons we have a military too trump
said if he threatened a nuclear exchange
on his watch he'd have submarines all
around russia saying
you should not do that trump says we
should give the migs and then some
here's what i would say that if putin
gets away with this china will take
taiwan and you worry about a new world
order president biden if we let the
ukrainian
people down and putin wins here china
will take taiwan and iran will get a
nuclear weapon but during this debacle
called
ukraine we're negotiating with the
iranians to give them a pathway to a
bomb so i miss president trump if you
could listen to him today please have
him on your show he would reassure you
it does not have to be this way well he
proved that it didn't have to be this
way and we had him on the show recently
and he said as much there's a reason
that uh the taliban didn't kill an
american around the last 18 months that
he was president and then they went on
the march when joe biden was sworn in uh
that's called peace through strength
in terms of america's role why would joe
biden veto poland giving migs to the
ukrainians so they can fight their own
war that seems like a mistake too
because putin owns biden biden is afraid
of escalation he's afraid of making
putin mad
as the troops were building up around
the ukraine republicans and democrats
that put sanctions on putin for the
provocation of a military buildup don't
wait to the invasion so here's two
questions the world needs to
ask and answer there's going to be a
nato summit here's what i would say on
your show to nato
if there's a chemical weapons attack by
the russian military against the
ukrainian people we should impose a
no-fly zone immediately because that's
breaking all the rules that we've
established since world war ii
if putin explodes a nuclear weapon
inside a ukraine the radiation will
affect most of europe we should consider
that attack on nato itself so the one
thing i've learned with bullies like
putin if you're not clear then they will
assume you're weak
so nobody assumed trump was weak you
know why putin didn't invade ukraine on
trump's watch because he didn't think
he'd get away with it taiwan is looking
at ukraine as a dress rehearsal this is
the most dangerous time in world history
since the 1930s so i'm begging nato to
let putin know
what would happen if he used chemical
weapons on the poor suffering people of
the ukraine we were to control the skies
through nato if he launches a nuclear
weapon if he explodes a nuclear weapon
in the ukraine to scare us all away we
should say the radiation coming to nato
countries is an attack on nato itself
and you're picking a fight with nato
well let's see what happens uh this is
what happens when you have a weak
american president that projects nothing
but weakness
senator graham of south carolina thank
you hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else